i'm louis jay gomez and i'm here to
answer the internet
[Music]
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
hundred-year-old man
or watch your mother kill someone um
well since both of my parents are dead i
would
rather watch either one of them do
either one of these to be honest with
you
just really a moment just a moment with
either one of them i would honestly give
up a year of my life to watch my mother
kill someone
uh if you could wipe one group of people
off the earth
who would it be puerto ricans
usually i'd give them like you know i'm
not saying like a race i need like a
group of fans or something like that no
no puerto ricans 100
were garbage people through and through
think of one can you name one positive
benefit of puerto rican has contributed
to society
nothing not a there's not one puerto
rican who inspires you
like you look up to i'm fi i'm
looking for him but they're not out
there i'm being honest with you it's the
name of puerto rican invention
even the puerto rican day parade they're
animals do you see what they do to the
their own people they have to lie
to lie down and sleep the only puerto
rican invention
is the laziest invention ever they
invented
and the pillow and inventors come on you
got to give me something here
it's hard to track it down here there's
something in there
juan cruz is an aerospace engineer that
literally sounds like you made up the
name
let's see uh would you rather be an
extremely good looking paralyzed person
or a
hideous fully functioning person so i'm
already a hideous fully functioning
person
um yeah i mean to be honest with you
you know what i mean let's say your
[ __ ] teeth are jacked up you got
you're missing one
eye you know you're a hunchback you're
[ __ ] you know you scare children when
you walk down the block
uh oh man does my dick work
uh if you're paralyzed or judgmental yes
okay uh i'd rather be a really good
looking paralyzed person i feel like you
get sympathy
you know as long as your dick works
you're pretty good how much money would
it take you to verbally belittle a
[ __ ] in front of a crowd of a hundred
people
i will pay 500 if you bring a [ __ ]
right now and i can
verbally belittle him and did you is it
belittle on purpose is that a that was
actually
that was a very low hanging fruit
barcelo sports
belittle gross would you rather let your
wife
[ __ ] you once with a strap on or take
her last name when you get married
um i mean that's just a real question i
gotta be honest with you uh
i gotta be honest with you i i mean she
might be able to convince me to just
[ __ ] me with a strap-on
you know is that just one time what's
the worst possible way for
someone to catch you jerking off i've
been i've been caught jerking
i got caught jerking off by my sister i
got caught i got caught jacked off by my
sister when i was 11 years old when i
was [ __ ] a teddy bear
that and i'm talking not he just [ __ ]
said i'm gonna slit in between the legs
there was a lot of explaining to do oh
yeah oh yeah
and she's how old she's two years older
than me yeah she knows exactly what's
going on
yeah it wasn't good
it was a really cheap teddy bear too it
was like the one that has the uh the
the styrofoam that falls apart inside of
it was really bad
so yeah she just disappeared my sister
disappeared for like five hours
afterwards
and i remember just thinking she's
disappeared i never saw her again enough
like fire
she there was like a wooded area behind
my house so she was gone for like five
hours i remember thinking at nine years
old like dear god in heaven i hope a
peck of wolves come and [ __ ] kill her
so then nobody will ever know that i
[ __ ] my teddy bear
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh or have to be a genocide
every time you fall in love i mean i
guess a dog die every time i laugh
once you have kids you stop giving a
[ __ ] about dogs i gotta be honest with
you
you could kill a dog in front of me
right now and i'm not gonna lose any
sleep over it
so if you could [ __ ] any girl you want
for the rest of your life but you could
only
ever watch women's sports would you do
it
uh yeah i don't watch any sports so
uh a hundred percent if i could [ __ ]
yeah i'm not even
doing it i know i watch a little bit of
mma but you know
female mma is pretty good too did you
stop masturbating if every girl you
jerked off to knew what you were doing
i would only come if these girls knew
what i was doing
are you kidding me um no i can never
stop masturbating
yeah it's it's an addiction would you
rather have free strippers for life or
free pizza for life i'll say you can't
[ __ ] a pizza
would you rather have a 10-inch dick
with no balls or a four-inch dick with
balls
i have a small dick in small balls so i
gotta be honest with you i'll take
either one but i probably take a ten
inch dick with no balls you always you
light you like the balls right
it's just something to do would you
rather give
the first 99 or the last one percent of
a [ __ ]
i think i'd rather give the last one
percent of a blow job get it out of the
way
yeah wash your mouth out a little bit
the salt's probably good for you would i
rather be me or magic johnson with the
aids magic johnson has the magical aids
that doesn't kill you
so yeah i'd rather be a seven foot tall
muscular black guy with the aids that
doesn't kill me in a billion dollars
then be a six foot one fat puerto rican
with
aids that's probably gonna kill me you
are
you're standing in the middle here you
are
one inch i mean again your parents are
dead so whatever
but you're one inch inside your mom
and behind you your dad is one inch
inside of you
do you move forward or do you move
backwards
uh well that's a great question
you move forward obviously i disagree
you really you'd move back into your dad
me and my dad can be like
you know that was weird son like you
kind of [ __ ] me there like
you know you [ __ ] me dad but like we're
just gonna put that away and we're just
like men we're gonna handle it
whereas for you know your mom it's like
you know that's that's
my zipper's down right now literally i'm
getting i'm getting turned on as we
speak
uh yeah i mean i guess the fact is like
there's nothing gay about letting your
dad [ __ ] you whereas you are actually
[ __ ] your mom
yeah you know i get that would you
rather have sex with a blind person or a
deaf person
uh i think i'd rather have sex with a
deaf person just because they sound
hilarious
yeah just i mean the whole time just the
way they moan it's [ __ ] hilarious
um yeah
yeah what are you saying
yeah for sure a deaf person